THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
SO SCARED COMMITTEE.
FIRST OFF AGAIN WILL HAVE A FEW
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
FIRST OF ALL SOME REMEMBER
OBERNOLTE HAS BEEN ASSIGNED TO
THE COMMITTEE DAY IN PLACE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRO.
SECOND WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. TWENTY FIFTY
TWO BONTA AND FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY SIX RODRIGUEZ
ARE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
KNOW WHAT TAKE OF THE CONSENT
CONSENT GALLAGHER.
AS SOON AS WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
THAT WAS STARTED SUBCOMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRO ONE GO HERE
AND PRESENT. OUR OWN I'M SORRY
IF THAT.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE MORNINGS.
THERE YOU GO.
NOT.
GO AHEAD WOULDN'T.
UNTIL RECENTLY FIRE PROTECTION
AND THE BIG BEAR VALLEY WITHIN
MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT HAS BEEN
PROVIDED BY TWO DIFFERENT
AGENCIES AND THE WEST END OF THE
VALLEY IT'S BEEN PROVIDED BY THE
BIG BEAR LAKE FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT.
AND ON THE EAST OF THE VALLEY
IT'S BEEN PROVIDED BY THE BIG
BEAR CITY COMMUNITY SERVICES
DISTRICT.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO A STUDY WAS
DONE THAT REVEALED THAT
CONSOLIDATING THOSE AGENCIES
INTO ONE ORGANIZATION WOULD
RESULT IN THE PROVISION OF
BETTER FIRE PROTECTION SERVICE
AT LOWER COST TO THE TAXPAYERS
AND THEREFORE. BOTH AGENCIES
VOTED TO ESTABLISH A NEW JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY CALLED THE BIG
BEAR FIRE AUTHORITY.
THE PLAN WAS ALWAYS TO TRANSPORT
THE EMPLOYMENT OF THE FIRE
PROTECTION PERSONNEL IN BOTH OF
THE AGENCIES TO THE NEW
AUTHORITY BUT ONE IMPEDIMENT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THAT THE TWO
AGENCIES UTILIZE DIFFERENT
RETIREMENT AGENCIES.
YEAH I THE FIRE THOUGHT THE OF
FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT
UTILIZES THE SAME MARINO COUNTY
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT AGENCY OR
S. B. SARAH. THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES DISTRICTS PERSONNEL ARE
WITH PURRS SO SEVERAL YEARS AGO
I AUTHORED A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT ALLOWS. THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES DISTRICT TO
TRANSFER ITS PURRS CURRENT PURSE
PERSONNEL TO THE FIRE AUTHORITY.
AND THE S. B. SARAH SYSTEM
WITHOUT THE OUR EMPLOYMENT THE.
TERMINATION LIABILITY.
AND THAT.
WAS SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR
HOWEVER RECENTLY A NEW
IMPEDIMENT HAS ARISEN AND.
APPARENTLY STATE LAW PROHIBITS
THIS BE SIERRA FROM TRANSFERRING
ITS EMPLOYEES FROM THE. A FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT TO THE FIRE
AUTHORITY WITHOUT IMPOSITION OF
TERMINATION LIABILITY EVEN
THOUGH BOTH AGENCIES ARE STAR
WITH S. B. SARAH SO THIS BILL AB
TWO THOUSAND FOUR CLARIFIES THAT
THE. AGENCY MAY TRANSFER THOSE
EMPLOYEES TO THE NEWLY CREATED
AUTHORITY WITHOUT TERMINATION
LIABILITY THIS WILL RESULT IN
THE PROVISION OF HIGHER QUALITY
FIRE SERVICE TO MY CONSTITUENTS
AT LOWER COST THE TAXPAYERS AND
I HOPE IT'S WORTHY OF YOUR
SUPPORT. WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO THOUSAND FOUR
TODAY IS JEFF WILLIS HE IS CHIEF
OF THE NEW BIG BEAR LAKE FIRE OR
THE.
NEW BIG BEAR FIRE AUTHORITY.
JEFF WILLIS.
RIGHT SO JUST DOES THE BACK UP
BUT AT SOME MENTAL PART
OBERNOLTE SAID IS THIS IS
BETTER.
A WORK IN PROGRESS FOR NEARLY
SIX YEARS.
AND IT'S BEEN KNOWN BY THE
GOVERNING BOARDS THAT YOU KNOW
THE TRANSFER PERSONNEL AND AND
ALL THAT GOES WITH IT IS PUBLIC
THE LARGEST HURDLE TO OVERCOME I
FEEL STRONGLY.
TO TODAY THAT THAT WILL PASS
PIECE OF ASSEMBLY BILL RIGHT
HERE THAT TO WILL BUILD
ACCOMPLISH THE GOAL.
THAT WE'VE BEEN IN PURSUIT OF
FOR NEARLY SIX SEVEN YEARS
SOMETHING LIKE THAT MAY ALSO ASK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
SO WITH THAT THAT WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
SO WHAT SECTORS LIKE KALRA
BEFORE CONTINUE.
RODRIGUEZ HERE.
ALLEN YOUR.
OBERNOLTE HERE.
THURMOND TESTS.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
O'DONNELL.
OKAY WITHOUT THE IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE.
WITH THAT.
WHEN GOVERNOR.
SO THAT ANY QUESTION COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THANK.
SO THAT I JUST HAVE A QUESTION
ARM.
SOME REMEMBER SO LAST YEAR THERE
IS AN ISSUE OF THE JPA THAT
CLOSE BECAUSE THE FUNDING WAS
TERMINATED.
THE JP THEN COMPATIBLE CATION
PENSION OBLIGATIONS AND THEIR
POISON TIRED OR NEGATIVELY
AFFECTED. AS ANY PROVISIONS IN
THIS BILL THAT WOULD YOU KNOW
PROTECT EMPLOYEES OF THAT WILL
BE THE CASE OF THIS WERE TO
HAPPEN.
THE QUESTION THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION MISTER CHAIRMAN THE I
CAN'T SPEAK TO THE CIRCUMSTANCES
SURROUNDING THE FAILURE OF THE
JPA LAST YEAR BUT I AM VERY
FAMILIAR WITH. THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF THIS PARTICULAR
JPA.
AND IN THIS CASE OF THE PROTECT
THE PROVISION OF FIRE PROTECTION
SERVICE IS THAT ONE OF THE
FUNDAMENTAL OUR RESPONSIBILITIES
OF THESE GOVERNMENTS. RIGHT NOW
THE EMPLOYMENT THE EMPLOYEES IN
THE VARIOUS AGENCIES RETIREMENTS
ARE PROTECTED BY THE.
OUR FINANCIAL RESOURCES OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE AGENCIES AND THE FIRE
AUTHORITY WILL HAVE ACCESS TO.
THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES OF BOTH
AGENCIES SO I WOULD ACTUALLY
OPINED THAT THE EMPLOYEES OF THE
NEW AUTHORITY ARE ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE MORE SECURE IN THEIR
RETIREMENT THEM THEY WERE
PREVIOUSLY.
WELL THANK YOU SO WITH THAT
THERE'S A MOTION AND SECOND.
OUR MOTION FORCES DO PASS I DO
HAVE A.
.
YES MOVES BEFORE SO WITH THAT
SECTOR TO CALL THE ROLL.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I.
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE.
OBERNOLTE BY OBERNOLTE AYE
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
O'DONNELL.
THE MOTION TO PASS YOUR FIVE
WELL WE'LL KEEP THE ROLL UP AND
FOR SOME MEMBERS TO ADD ON TO
LIKE. THINK THAT MISTER.
SO WITH THAT AS WELL.
SECRETARY LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUR
MOTION AND SECOND.
A MOTION AND A SECOND BY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY IT SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES.
SECTOR LIKE CALDERON CONSENT
CALENDAR.
RODRIGUEZ AYE RODRIGUEZ AYE
ALLEN AYE ALLEN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER O'DONNELL.
SURE THAT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS APPROVED FIVE OH KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW MINUTES FOR
MISSING MEMBERS WITHOUT IT WILL
GO AHEAD AND KEEP IT OPEN.
AND WHAT TREATMENTS FOR THE
OTHER MEMBERS
SECRETARY OF A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL WHICH LIKE TO ADD ON
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SECRETARY CALDERON.
BY.
O'DONNELL I.
ALSO WITH THAT WOULD HAVE. A
BEAT TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR
OBERNOLTE ROCKED AT ON TO THAT
AS WELL.
SECRETARY CALDERON.
THE DOLLAR.
O'DONNELL I
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU STILL
MISSING ONE MEMBER IT'S IN ROUTE
SO HOLD OPEN THE ROLE FOR A FEW
MORE MINUTES.
THANK YOU
JERRY OF SOME
NUMBER.
COOPER HERE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IF.
I.
COOPER I.
COOPER ALRIGHT ON ALSO ON THE
FILE ITEM A. B. TWO ZERO ZERO
FOUR OBERNOLTE.
SECRETARY KALRA.
I'VE
COOPER.
COOPER I.
BOTH MEASURE OUT WITHOUT WILL GO
AHEAD AND TURN.
TODAY'S MEANING OF PURSE THANK
YOU